je vous raconte tout un geste espace ça
dans mon oreillette comme c'est en régie
influence sebaoun voilà qui fait
n'importe quoi à quelques danses et
voilà comme je les aime beaucoup mais
bon ce moment allait surtout les mecs
elle est partie à ibiza semaine dernière
ses mythes
cela promet que les animations c'est
mykonos la semaine prochaine elle a
laissé en fait l'oreillette branché donc
j'entends comme un bon voilà toute
triche pas j'ai l'impression qu'à
nicolas hulot qui souffle dans mon
oreille voilà merci mais personne ne
fait rien résoudre alors merci c'est ça
la france
retour en terre inconnue qui était très
long chez vous n'êtes pas fan de cette
émission je suis un petit peu
voilà je sais que vous et gilles verdez
vous êtes un petit peu énervé par retour
en terre inconnue on va en parler tout
de suite c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gars est-ce que vous avez vu des
jingle qui partent plus longtemps après
jacques ehrmann
après cinq minutes que j'ai dit jingle
bell et garçons qu'est ce qu'il a dit
des choses
qu'est ce qu'il veut lui porte l on est
tranquille notera de fumée des pets quoi
ça le job qu'on envoie les truies quoi
ça m'a fait des tours alors on régis
vous m'écoutez pas parce que vous
n'arrêtez pas en fait un merci bah si
c'est pas toi non parce qu'il ya
florence poli mais c'est pas moi c'est
dur pour moi c'est toi
voilà pour moi c'est toi
il est avec moi
souvent des cris souvent avec moi si
j'avais tué a tu de la déploie toute sa
magie
ap
ça va pas non plus se faire les dents
mais voilà mais qu'est ce que tu as tué
par balle qui comment ça se fait que ça
s'ouvre dans mon oreille je veux des
responsables déjà il ya un gars là il a
encore des oeufs de pâques dans ses
cheveux
non mais c'est bon alors qu'ils surent
l'occupent sais qui je veux c'est quoi
asselah c'est là bas on va sérieux tout
vous montrer les gars on se fout de ma
gueule
justin bieber c'est toi qui es en train
de mettre des trucs dans mon oreille
mais non non tu sais qui c'est qui si
justin c'est justin bieber sa faune
justin justin bieber et je te dis moi
alors il ya même un gardien pour le
servette
alors c'est d'ici c'est d'ici que ne
partent pas tous les sous ne touche pas
à mon poste
voilà vous savez des sons tu partes
bahamas et euh c'est quoi le responsable
ouais
oui oui le son en appuyant d'accord il
pourquoi t'as pas piller pour le son oui
pourquoi devenu son tu veux cohn bandit
alors on voit trop et que la vie à plus
de 27
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
pas mal en année je vais appuyer sur
l'eau je vais m'appuyer sur le aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu sois là que des musiques de merde en
fait à merde non merde c'est david
guetta revient demain c'est vachement
bien parce que j'entends pas dit si en
fait je me fous dans la mer de toi je me
fous la merde je te le dis merci en tout
cas c'est super sympa m merci et vous
savez j'ai toujours le bourdonnements
dans l'oreille d'accord merci salut les
gars merci d'être passé